yes I am currently playing The Last of
Us and I'll do a video in the Last of Us
when I beat The Last of Us but I take a
break from my apocalyptic game involving
infected people that are zombie light to
talk about an apocalyptic movie
involving infected people who are
actually zombies because Ami's and
zombie like people they're just awesome
these are truths these are facts
World War Z so World War Z stars Brad
Pitt it's ultimately it's a zombie movie
you knew that already though I love
movies like this that shows the
outbreaks start I love those first
couple days of just chaos and Anarchy
and people are freaking out in their
looting stores it just feels very real
the rest of the movie I don't know if it
would happen like that those first
couple days I'm pretty sure it would and
now Brad Pitt must travel the globe to
find out where this outbreak started
maybe they can find a cure that's the
purpose of the movie Brad Pitt's like
Dustin Hoffman and outbreak he has his
sidekick in the movie who's straight-up
Jack from Mass Effect 2 so things are
looking good for him shit's gonna get
done [ __ ] his business and when I saw
the trailer for this movie I was like
alright everything looks very CGI I
don't know if I'm gonna buy this over
scenes that did look very CGI other
scenes look pretty real I mean real
issue anyway I've seen fakers [ __ ]
thrown on the screen sometimes the
framerate looked a little choppy but you
can pass that off as they're just they
move very twitch like they're all like
it was a realistic representation dude
as cool as it was seeing the zombie [ __ ]
because like I said before I love me the
zombie apocalypse and you do too why are
you here face it the formula the movie
seemed very rinse and repeat Brad Pitt
goes to a place there are zombies around
there but people have a handle on things
and then [ __ ] hits the fan Brad Pitt has
to leave he goes to another place in
which there are zombies around but they
seem to have a handle on things [ __ ]
hits the fan Brad Pitt has to leave and
then he goes to another place what
happens you guessed it there are zombies
around but they seem to have a handle of
it you get it like they were like
alright we're gonna show Altima the same
scenario over and over again but the
situation's will vary for varieties sake
however this was a really cool zombie
apocalypse movie there's there's a
segment in the movie where they have to
walk down these hallways and are trying
to be quiet it reminded me of aliens how
they're walking down the really dark
hallways and they have the motion
sensors I'll bet they're intense you
know they don't have a motion sensor in
this movie but it reminded me of aliens
you know that's all I'm saying however
the coolest part of the movie is halfway
into the movie when all the zombies are
piling up on each other like ants
after that the movie never gets as cool
as that was I like the intense dark
hallway segments you know for varieties
sake that was actually really cool you
don't always need to have guns for
intensity you know those dark hallways
that that'll do it but it felt like the
movie was building to something really
big and they just kind of built to a
crawl than a montage to the end of the
movie you're like oh I guess the movies
over now just left you wanting you're
like wait a minute what what just
happened that's it that's how they're
gonna leave it maybe they're leaving it
open for a sequel look come on
give us enough to leave the movie
theater going yeah that was completely
fulfilling kind of bummed me out
also Brad Pitt's family in the movie I
get why he has a family because he has
to have something to fight for but I was
thinking about it I was like if they
didn't give him a wife and two kids in
this movie the movie would be no
different the only thing they really
contribute is the fact that he has to
call home every once in a while to say
hey I'm still alive but really that's it
they exist for him but you don't really
feel anything for him they could have
all died in the intro of this movie and
the movie would have been no different I
did leave the movie theater feeling like
they could have done a lot more in a
zombie apocalypse movie about a guy
looking for a cure whose wife and kids
are left back home and that you could
have done a lot with that if you're
letting utilize all of it but it was
still a really cool zombie apocalypse
movie you get some really cool [ __ ]
especially for a pg-13 movie or a couple
scenes where you're like I hope there's
a director's cut because I want the
zombie apocalypse Gore I love the fact
that they actually call them zombies -
in media these days they never use the
word zombie they call them walkers
runners infected never zombies it's
almost like they're like yeah we can't
call them the c-word that's that's
copyrighted this movies are like no
zombie we said it they are zombies I
love that as trivial as that sounds that
made me go yeah good call World War Z if
you're a zombie fanatic if you're a
zombie aficionado you're gonna have a
lot of fun in this movie it's not the
best zombie apocalypse movie ever made
but World War Z is a good time no
alcohol required I haven't read the book
but I heard this movie deviates so much
from the source material that if you're
a fan of the book you might walk out and
go not this movie which also makes me
think if they stuck with the source
material I might have walked out of this
movie going sweetest movie ever Jurassic
park's like the one that can do it the
movie that can deviate from the source
material so much and still make a
sweet-ass movie it's a World War Z have
you seen it what's your favorite zombie
apocalypse story and yeah if they're
infected ravenous Raby people who aren't
actually undead I think that counts in
this day and age those kind of stories
have been inducted into the zombie
apocalypse family whatever your favorite
is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you